chaud alors tokyo l'option samson où en
est la chanson parce qu'en ce moment la
chanson française est envahie par les
reprises une reprise c'est quand on
reprend un vieux succès en la rangeant à
peu et on va savoir si les reprises
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien si les gens
aiment ça au système pas ça et surtout
qu'est ce que ça fait aux jeunes auteurs
compositeurs qui ont du mal à s'exprimer
alors nous ont rejoint pour ce plateau
stéphane bonsoir alors tu es fan ça fait
ça fait un moment font déjà pas bu vous
êtes sur scène en ce moment vous êtes
aux coulisses 5 rue du mont-cenis de
caen à caen le 12 ou le 13 mai le 12 et
le 13 mais bon c'est pas le 12 et 13
mars depuis le mois de décembre je fais
des concerts tous les mois de concerts
autres concerts par mois
oui ont montré un petit peu de quoi je
suis capable donc de chanter parce que
c'est le métier que j'ai choisi et que
j'aime et vous avez la mesure sa
tristement c'est bien de chandelles et
ou non j'aime j'aime ce métier non je
suis calme de nature à c'est très bien
c'est pas comme moi alors donc il ya
stephen il ya thierry séchan bonsoir il
ya rachid car alors syrie
alors thierry séchan vous êtes vous êtes
le frère de renaud et vous êtes encore
plus énervant que soit son but sa joie
est encore plus énervant que votre frère
j'essaie vous y arrivez le musée est
auteur journaliste [ __ ] traducteur
chanteur parolier
alors j'ai fait des paroles d'ailleurs
c'est vrai pour julien clerc pour la
voie pour elsa mais vous avez déclaré je
refuse de devenir barbelivien et comme
je peux pas être d'agile je m'auto
détruits et vous vous êtes auto détruit
d'ailleurs avec un certain nombre de
livres que je montre à la caméra ça pour
s'autodétruire vous êtes fort qui
s'appelle nos amis les chanteurs là vous
balancer sur tout le métier
vous parlez de pascal sevran et je peux
en dire du mal si on lui dit le sujet de
passionnant vous dites ne vous dis pas
du mal vie de pascal même bien même si
c'est pas forcément un cadeau
cela dit ça mais je croyais que tu avais
lu mes livres
moi j'ai vu les tiens j'avais pas
j'avais pas chercher mon grand tu es
libre il a beaucoup de courage il entre
il est très bien la hongrie à toi tu
perds mais oui il est il écrit très bien
et il envoie pas dire ce qu'il a envie
de dire à 80% je pourrais être consigné
ses livres je trouve qu'ils sont qu un
jeu qui entoure et il sait très bien
décrire et donc c'est déjà une qualité
formidable rachita vous profitez
lentement c'est génial et une vague dure
à l on a vu où victoire la semaine
dernière 1 2 3 soleil s'est vendu à 500
mille exemplaires vous l'avez le dit
cela laurent avec d'autre part la voilà
mais ça c'est un petit single je vais la
maison mais voilà montrer le ouais moi
j'ai connu du rai rap bien qui rira le
dernier parce que ouais parce que non
mais c'est vrai qu'à une espèce de
d'effervescence sur le rail
mais c'est l'arbre cache la forêt quand
même bien l'espèce de demandes du coton
regarde profondément quand on regarde
les médias et ceux qui diffusent le rail
n'a pas beau wave ou de radio de médias
québécois soit il ya un côté c'est vrai
peut-être un peu traître et soirée très
combien là ce soir on va écouter du rail
oui tout ça mais en fait les
profondément yahia est encore un
problème vis-à-vis de nos gars
c'est à dire programme ne naît pas
véritablement diffusé d'une manière
générale quand ton pote mais j'ai chaque
jour avec papa loire merde quoi mais
c'est comme ouais alors la semaine
dernière la semaine dernière aux
histoires c'était c'était effectivement
une une soirée spéciale vous allez
chanter d'ailleurs il ya un single qui
sort c'est une reprise on en arrive aux
reprises on va regarder un petit magnéto
avec plein de reprise de danger